Rrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr In Amerika verstehen sie keinen Spaß beim Podcast-Ufo, Podcast-Ufo. Wow, herzlich willkommen, schön, dass ihr da seid bei der neuen Folge von Das Podcast-Ufo. Das Podcast-Ufo, es klingt wirklich, als wäre es eine Sitcom. Ich hatte wirklich den Drang, mich so nach reinzudrehen in die Kamera. Ja, mit Florentin Will. Und Stefan Dietze. Mach dich die Hände so. Und ich finde, jetzt sollten wir nach jedem Themenblock, den wir haben, so ein kinderfriesartiges Gitarren-Zwischenspiel haben. Ja, das finde ich richtig gut. Vielen, vielen Dank an Markus für dieses grossartige Intro. Markus mit C oder mit K? Mit C haben wir das geschrieben. Markus, also vielen, vielen Dank. Interessanter Künstlername hat er sich ja ausgewählt. Das, glaube ich, wird dich noch weit treiben. Markus, das heißt Steffen. Ich habe letztens überlegt, was gute Namen für dich auch wären. Ich habe über, ich versuche ja eine Karriere. Warum überlegen? Ich versuche ja so ein bisschen, na, manchmal überlege ich mir so, was, weil ich denke mir immer so, okay, welcher meiner, sagen wir jetzt mal nicht, Freunde, Bekannten könnte jemanden umbringen, halt so. Und würde ich dann den Mord decken oder würde ich dann, also an dem Du rufst mich an. Du rufst jetzt schon einen prophylaktischen neuen Namen für mich. Genau. Also nur eine Identität. Das ist schon so ein neuer Personalausweis in der Hinterhand. Ich habe schon so eine Trainingstasche gepackt, weil ich denke mir immer so, du rufst mich ab drei nachts an so, hey Florentina, ich habe Scheiße gebaut ey, scheiße, der Elektriker war nochmal da und dann hat er gesagt, meine Stühle sehen scheiße aus und dann habe ich irgendwie... Long story short, Felix Lubrecht ist tot. Genau. Und ich so, beweg dich nicht vom Flag, ich bin in zehn Minuten bei dir. Jemand kommt, jemand steht schon vor deiner Tür. Ich bin dafür, ich habe dafür vorgesagt, jemand steht vor deiner Tür. Und dazu gehört natürlich auch, also ich gehe natürlich davon aus, dass es dann erstmal klappt, die Leiche und so, aber dann Staffel zwei, irgendjemand hat es dann doch gesehen, geht zur Polizei und dann Staffel drei oder so, wirst du dann gefasst. Und dann ist natürlich die Frage so, welchen Namen gibt man sich als Mörder, ist ja auch wichtig so, du brauchst ja dann so eine Imageberatung. Und dann, wie geht man da rein in so ein Briefing,
wie man so einen Namen macht?
Und ich dachte mir vielleicht mal was Nettes vielleicht irgendwie.
Ich habe auch neulich eine fantastische True-Crime-Dokumentation
angeguckt, bin ich so die beste ...
American Murderer?
Nope.
Staircase Killer?
Ja, hab ich auch geguckt, fand ich auch gut, aber es ist noch besser. Es ist wirklich die beste True-Crime-Serie. Also objektiv, ich hab alle geguckt, von daher kann ich sagen, es ist objektiv die beste. Weil ich finde auch, wenn jemand alle Filme gesehen hat, kann er sagen, das ist der objektiv beste Film. Völlig okay, legitim. Also immer dieses Subjektivismus, Quatsch, nein, das ist der objektiv beste Film. Und das ist die objektiv beste True-Crime-Dokumentation, heißt I'll Be Gone in the Dark. Und zwar ist das von der Frau von Patton Oswalt, die Frau Spence von King of Queens. Auch den Kreis wieder geschlossen. Um den Kreis zu schliessen. Der hatte eine fantastische Frau, Michelle McNamara, die vor allem einen der ganz tollen True-Crimediary.com hatte, also sozusagen ein bisschen True-Crime auch gest hat und cool aufbereitet hat, konnte er wahnsinnig gut schreiben, selbst Stephen King hat die wahnsinnig in den Himmel gelobt. Und die hat dann lange einen Fall recherchiert über den East Area Rapist. Und der wurde auch Original Night Stalker genannt. Das ist ein guter Name. Ja, das ist ein guter Name. Und sie hat dann den Namen Golden State Killer begründet. Wenn jemand weiß, der Golden State Killer. Und das war schon cool. Aber da wurde es auch erst cool. Ich finde, East Area Rapist, finde ich ... Naja, ist das so eine Entwicklung irgendwie so? Original Night Stalker finde ich cool, weil das klingt so ... Es gibt auch Nachahmer, aber er ist der Original Night Stalker. Das könnte dann auch ein Superheld sein. Also die Grenzen zwischen Superheld und Serienmörienmörder. Original Night Stalker. The Real Night Stalker. Ja, Night Stalker Official. Unglaublich gruselig. Du haust aber auch Empfehlungen raus. Ich habe nur noch Urlaubstaffin, entdeckt mal wieder Dinge. So, und dann habe ich das geguckt. Und ich bin wirklich nicht anfällig für sowas. Also ich kann auch gut Horrorfilme gucken oder so, auch alleine und dann abends alleine schlafen. Alles easy. Diese Serie konnte ich nicht gucken, ich konnte nicht schlafen. Ich habe die ganze Nacht, ich habe die ersten drei Folgen ausgesucht und ich habe nachts wach im Bett gelegen und habe auf die Straße runtergeguckt, ob da jemand steht. Ich konnte es nicht ertragen. Und wie die ganze, ich will es gar nicht erzählen genau, aber die ist dann jedenfalls gestorben, das weiß man wissen viele ja, ganz, ganz tragisch. Und Patton Oswalt hat dann beschlossen, dass das Buch rausgebracht wird und diese True Crime Serie beruht auf dem Buch, I'll Be Gone in the Dark, das ist ein Catchphrase, den er immer gesagt hat zu den Opfern. Er hat um die fünfzig Frauen vergewaltigt, Serien-Rapist und irgendwie noch zwanzig ungewandt. Grauenhafter Typ, wirklich grauenhafter Typ und diese Story, also die ganze Dinge. Also privat auch meinst du jetzt. Riesenarschloch, privat, privat, privat, leit sich immer Filme, gibt die nicht zurück. Aber wie das endet, das kann man sich nicht vorstellen. Lest nichts darüber, guckt I'll Be Gone in the Dark, leider HBO, leider HBO, weil man das nicht gut gucken kann. Nicht, weil ich HBO per se hasse. Geil. Also Netflix ist schon cooler, aber HBO ist jetzt auch nicht schlecht. Und das kann man aber leider nicht so gut gucken. Vielleicht kriegt ihr das irgendwie hin. Unbedingt anschauen. Und da ist nämlich die Frage, ich habe mir immer gefragt, wer gibt es solchen Leuten den Namen? Weil manche heißen dann irgendwie Uncle Sam, wo man denkt so als Mörder so nie. Ich glaube, das ist halt auch wirklich Teil der Ermittlung, weil es gibt ja in jedem guten Krimi dann irgendwann den Fall, wo der Mörder dann im Verhör sitzt und dann wird so verhandelt, so im Sinne von so, okay, wir gehen auf, sie kriegen nicht die Todesstrafe, dafür sagen sie uns, wo die Leichen sind. Und dann überlegt er und sagt, lassen Sie das mit der Todesstrafe beibehalten, ich sage euch, wo die Leichen sind, dafür kriege ich einen coolen Namen. Du kriegst einen halb coolen Namen?
Ja.
Dafür verzichten wir ...
Eine Leiche zeig ich euch.
Okay, lebenslange Haftstrafe.
Ja.
Dafür kriegst du einen uncoolen Namen und du sagst uns trotzdem, wo die Leichen sind.
Nee, lass uns mal einen coolen ... Ich will irgendwie so ...
Ich schreib jetzt auf diesem Set einen Namen.
Mhm.
Und dann werde ich ihn dir zuschieben.
Mhm. Und du wirst sagen, ob du damit die Todesstrafe annimmst, okay? Okay. Mach Original davon, wir haben Deal. Deal. So läuft's doch. So natürlich läuft das so. Das ist doch eigentlich das beste Druckmittel gegen einen Serienmörder, den du hast. Ja, wir haben uns jetzt überlegt so, das Kätzchen von Ehrenfeld haben wir uns überlegt. Was? Das Kätzchen? Also nicht, dass ich es war, aber ... Weil sie so leise sind. Sie waren so leise ... Wenn ich der Mörder wäre, dann fände ich das unfair, weil ich sag mal so, meine Spezialität ist ja der Schraubenzieher. Also die des Mörders. Weil sie gerade meinen. Nein, nein, nein, des Mörders. Und deswegen dachte ich halt mir so der Dreher oder so, der Schrauber oder halt sowas, der Schrauber von Ehrenherr. Das Schäuberle. Da können wir, nein, lass doch die Verniedrigungsform mal beiseite. Ich hab das nur Kätzchen, weil sie ja wie auf Samtfoten das Kätzchen. Ja. Also in meinem Vorschlag wäre das Kätzchen. Ich habe nichts gegen Kätzchen, nur ich glaube, es ist halt ... Catman? Hier kommt's, the Catman? I'm the Catman, dude. Ja, ja, ja. I'm the Catman. Das ist nicht schlecht. Jetzt, wo ich nachdenkenken bin ich doch für Kätzchen. Weil sie waren so, also die
ganzen Frauen haben sich auch irgendwie als
süss bezeichnet, so mit kindlichen
Gesichtszügen.
Na ja, das würde ich jetzt einfach gerne
nochmal ins Verhör reingucken.
Das haben die gesagt.
Das war auch so krass und dann haben die alle gesagt,
zum Glück haben wir Trigger Warnings
mittlerweile, also von daher haben wir das.
Wir sind vorgesagt. Weil alle haben dann in den Bericht geschrieben, über diese schrecklichen Taten,
ihr anzitier den Bericht, Stefan.
Excessive small penis.
Alle haben das gesagt, excessively small penis.
Puh, Gott.
Wo man aber auch als Mörder denkt, das habe ich, also das hat der, gut, hat 50 Frauen vergewaltigt und 20 umgebracht, aber das hat er nicht verliebt. Wie viele Leichen müsste ich euch zeigen, bis ihr da nur small draußen wart? Wie viele Männer habt ihr geschlafen, dass ihr so eine Skala habt, dass ihr nicht eine Skala habt klein, mittel, gross, sondern dass es dann noch ein excessively small gibt. Naja, aber guck dich diese Doku an, fantastisch, also wirklich, ich bin, ich freue mich letztens noch auf die Instagram-Nachricht, nachdem ihr die letzte Folge geguckt habt. Ganz toll, also ich bin wirklich, ich habe Gänsehaut im ganzen Körper immer noch. Ich kann aber auch American Murder empfehlen, weil es ist keine Serie. Es ist endlich mal wieder ein True Crime Film. Es ist endlich mal 90 Minuten und es ist ein fantastischer Film. Und ich war wirklich 90 Minuten lang, habe ich wirklich wenig geatmet. Ich habe wirklich mich so angespannt gefühlt. Ich glaube, ich habe wirklich ein Kilo abgenommen während diesem Film. Weil ich war so angespannt einfach die ganze Zeit. Was ist deine Strategie? Ja, Horrorfilme, einfach True Crime. Ich hänge von so einer Stange, während ich Filme angucke. Und das ist ganz gut. Und dann kann ich wie bei so einem Grill, unten habe ich so eine Pfanne, wo das Fett reintropft. Und dann kannst du das noch schön weiterverwenden. Finde ich nicht schlecht eigentlich. Aber das ist wirklich auch spannend. Und vor allem auch, dass da immer so diese Chatverläufe gezeigt werden. Das finde ich immer so ein bisschen, dass da niemand mal Gags macht oder so. Bei den Chats. Ja, irgendwie so dann, wo halt der mit seiner Frau spricht und so halt, die Frau ist verschwunden und dann ist natürlich die Frage, hat der Ehemann was damit zu tun oder nicht? Und dann zeigen die immer so diese Chats und die posten da nie mal ein Meme oder irgendwie so mal guck mal der Hund, rutscht da die Treppe runter oder so, gar nichts. Immer nur so ganz trockene Sachen. Dramatisch, ja. Also das würde ich wollen, dass wenn ich irgendjemanden umbringe, dass dann zumindest auch mal ein paar Premium-Gags einfach mal in die Doku kommen. Weil wir alle wissen, die besten Gags finden im Privaten statt. Ich bin ganz ehrlich, also du erzählst sehr viel über dein Privatleben und so und wir kennen uns ja auch schon lange, aber so ganz greife ich dich noch nicht. Und ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt, so ein Mord würde einfach viel auch erklären. Und es wäre auch irgendwie, so ein Mord würde uns auch als Podcast helfen, irgendwie. Ja, weil es wird nochmal irgendwie jetzt, das wäre so die nächste Runde. Ja, so ein echter True-Crime-Podcast. Das wäre so die nächste Staffel. Ja, genau, wir haben so eine True-Crime-Staffel, wo du versuchst, den Mord aufzuklären. Den du begangen hast. Ich immer versuche, dich da von der Fährte abzulenken. Ach so, und dann am Ende erst rauskommen, was du mir begangen hast. Genau, ich versuche mal vom Thema abzulenken. Du immer so, jetzt habe ich da diesen gelben Gummistiefel im Garten gefunden. Und ich, weißt du noch, als bei Fluch der Karibik, die diese Kanonenkugel geschossen haben, mit der Kette, die den Mast abgeschossen, mit den zwei Kanonenkugeln, wie geil war das denn, oder? War schon geil. Ja, stimmt, das ist mega.
Und ich bin auch viel zu leicht abzulenken.
Genau.
Ein Detektiv, viel sich abzulenken.
Aber das Gute an dir als Detektiv ist, du hast kein Privatleben.
Also du bist das genaue Gegenteil von allen Detektivs, die je in Krimis gespielt haben.
Ja, so wie bei Zodiac.
Ich habe keine Frau, die dann plötzlich mit den Kindern wegrennt.
Bei mir ist einfach, löst es und dadurch werde ich noch jemanden kennen. Das wäre ja auch immer schön. Genau, die immer das Beweismaterial rausgibt und dann die ungeräte Story. Und dann so, es tut mir leid, aber ich muss mich um diesen Fall kümmern. Nee, ist okay, Schatz, ist okay, kein Problem, ich bin hier unten. Kein Ding. Und ich bin auch selber schockiert, weil ich durch Filme kennenlerne, dass man eigentlich...
Nee, mach nur, kein Problem.
Nee, ich bring die Kinder zu meiner Mutter und dann...
Sie haben gestern schon zwölf Stunden gearbeitet daran.
Ja, kein Problem.
Das ganze Schlafzimmer steht mit Beweismitteln voll.
Ja, ich weiß, ich finde das eine nette Atmosphäre, ich mag das gern.
Wenn du mit mir über den Fall reden willst, gerne.
Jetzt klingt, als wärst du der Mörder, wenn ich so...
Und es ist immer Tag, es ist immer Tag in dieser Serie. Sonst bei Krimis immer nachts und da ist immer Tag. Tag im Popmusik. Immer so Pfadfinderinnen kommen vorbei und so und helfen und man... Alles ist gut. Ist gut. Ist alles gut? Aber es ist keine Serie für dich, wo du abnehmen kannst. Das ist eine Serie, wo du zu nehmen kannst. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Aber gut. Nee, da habe ich schön irgendwie das Sechzehner-Park-MMass in Unterarm und schieben wir eine, haben andere rein. Immer erst in der Packung, in der Hand halten, wärmen und dann, wenn es so richtig schleimig, schmatzig ist, dann schön sich in die Kehle schieben in einem Stück. Du magst es schmatzig? Ich mag's schmatzig, quatschig, spatzig. Richtig schön aufgewärmt, richtig schmatschig.
Zwei davon waren Wörter.
Das andere wird noch ein Wort. Erst richtig schön aufwärmen und dann einfach mal reinkägeln. Voll gut. Ich habe letzte Folge gesagt, ich hätte immer mehr Bock auf dem Freizeitpark. Wo war ich gestern? Nein! Hansa Park! Ich war schön im Phantasialand. Ich war noch nie im Phantasialand, direkt neben Köln, in Köln-Brühl. Bisschen assige Gegend, ganz ehrlich, aber schon cool. Also, wahnsinnig cooler Park, habe ich so gar nicht am Schirm gehabt, dass es auch so ein großer Park ist mit so vielen Attraktionen. Was ist da das Maskottchen? Ist es nicht Wumbo? Nee, das war Hans-Heide-Park gewesen. Wumbo ist da nicht mehr. Und Hans-Heide-Park hat kein Maskottchen. Na, wieso denn? Nee, das ist ja, aber ich mag das, weil das ist ja so ein Off-Brand-Freizeitpark. Also ich kenne, als Freizeitpark-Connoisseur, der ich ja bin. Lego, super krasses Franchise, Disney, Universal, dann gibt's den Movie-Park Germany, der Warner Bros. Park. Ja, also der Bärenmarke Freizeitpark, wo alles so um Milch und Bären dreht, wo man sich auch nicht denkt, ist das eine gute Richtung für diese Firma? Dann der Ferdifuchs. Genau, konkurriert mit dem Späfuchs Freizeitpark. Späfuchs, die beiden Füchse, die seit Jahren im Clinch sind und sie gegenseitig die Achterbahnschrauben aufdrehen. Der Wüstenrotfuchs, der sich raushält, der einfach sagt, Leute, das ist euer Scheißding. Ja, ausserdem, ich bin scheisse reich, ich bin so reich, ich könnte eure beiden Parks kaufen, will ich aber nicht. Ich habe so viele Bauscharverträge, ich kann mir jedes Jahr ein Haus kaufen. Warum ist der Fuchs, naja, weil er schlau ist, deswegen liebt man den als Moskotter. Er ist schlau, ja, und weil er halt Würstchen liebt. Der Charming Bear, ganz grau nach dem Freizeitpark, wirklich schlimmer Freizeitpark. Auch alles mit so einem Pup-Thema. Alles so weich, ja, aber alles so ganz weich. Wer saß da schon drauf vor mir? Nee, jedenfalls, Phantasial ist auch ein Off-Brand-Freizeitpark, also einfach Fantasy grob. Aber dadurch haben sie es wahnsinnig cool gemacht. Die haben halt alles so, die haben eine, es ist ein bisschen, ich habe es nicht ganz verstanden, das System. Also ich könnte es auch, den Freisagspark könnt ihr nicht gut pitchen, ganz ehrlich, weil es gibt Berlin, dann gibt es Mexiko und das war alles aus der normalen Welt.
Dann gibt es die Fantasy-World mit so ganz viele Tierchen aus dem Naturbereich, Kobolde, Elfen, sowas, so eine Welt, die verstehe ich. Dann gibt es Mystery, das ist sozusagen eher so eine Mittelalterwelt, also so Mittelalter-Mystery, also so teilweise, er wird aus einer Burg, da ist er aber auch ein alter Professor, der dann so mit Tesla-Spulen was macht und so, dann Kobolde, die festgehalten werden in so einer, also so eine, da trifft so ein bisschen, ist ja so eine Herr der Ringe artige Mystery Fantasy Welt. Okay. Mit so kleinen Herr der Ringe mit Tesla Spuren im Grunde. Ja, das ist das fällt da auch ein bisschen raus. Ja, naja und dann gibt es so eine Steampunk Welt und dann gibt es aber Berlin, auch genau, dann gibt es noch Afrika, Berlin und Mexiko. Also ich habe, ich verstehe nicht genau, wie das passieren kann. The worst of both worlds. Es ist the worst of both worlds. Das schlechteste von der echten Welt und das schlechteste von der fiktiven Welt. Und dann gibt es so eine Cowboy-Achterbahn noch, die steht aber in Mexiko, wo ich sage, okay, wenn, dann hätte ich sie auch da reingestellt, aber warum brauchst du die in the first place? Naja, andere Frage, aber war auch cool zu fahren.
Und das ist aber der ganz tolle Freizeitpark, auch viel mit Liebe zum Detail und so was und tollen Restaurants und so was. Und mir ist mir auch gefallen, wie stressig das ist, so ein Freizeitparktag, weil der von 10 bis 18 Uhr auf ist ja auch nicht so billig, der Eintritt, hat 50 Euro gekostet, sondern willst du natürlich auch den ganzen Tag ausnutzen. Und dann ist das kulinarische Angebot natürlich auch toll, also man will auch dann zweimal essen gehen. Das heißt, man muss da mit jemandem hingehen, damit man sich auch gut auf einer Wellenlänge ist, damit man schön zu gleichen Zeiten hungrig ist. Du brauchst hungrige Freunde, ja. Weil du stehst immer an, ne? Also das ist wirklich eine Wartezeit, das geht wirklich netto auf die Zeit, die du Freitagpark hast drauf. Also du darfst nicht irgendwie getrennte Rhythmen haben, ne? Du musst schon gemeinsam essen gehen. Ja, du musst schon sagen, jetzt würde ich gerne eine Dreiviertelstunde warten. Solche Leute brauchst du. Solche Leute brauchst du. So, und dann ist es ein bisschen so, man geht in eine Achterbahn, steht dann da auch ein bisschen an. Gerade bei Corona-Zeit war es relativ angenehm. Steht dann da 30 Minuten an, fährt dann damit, redet zehn Sekunden, hoho, boah, das war cool, oder? Ja, das war mega, ja, das war cool.
Und dann macht es, weil man will den Freizeitparkplan rausholen, um zu nächsten Attraktionen zu hetzen, natürlich, weil man will ja auch, ist ja auch undurchsichtig so ein Park, ist ja auch nicht, ist ja wie so ein grosser Irrgarten. Er ist so gebaut, dass man nicht rausfindet.
Dass man nie rausfindet.
Wenn es einen Park nicht nötig hat, dann einen Freizeitpark.
Das ist nicht so schlimm, da will man gar nicht raus. Und dann muss man halt zur nächsten Achterbahn. Dann ist man tatsächlich sehr schnell wieder in einem ... So, jetzt zur nächsten Attraktion, man will auch ein bisschen was sehen. Ja. Wie muss man sich dich in einer Achterbahn vorstellen? Bist du wirklich so ein Wuhu, Hände hoch oder eher skeptisch oder eher, ich muss gar nicht zeigen, dass ich Spaß habe, mir reicht das Innere erleben oder wie muss man sich da dich vorstellen? Nee, also Arme hoch ist mir zu krass, weil ich bin ganz ehrlich, ich bin ein paar Achterbahnen gegangen, da stand nur bis maximal 1,95 Meter, so ich bin 1,97 Meter. Und dann schwingt schon so ein ... Vor oder nach Passgrößenbetrug.
Man muss sich kurz nachfragen.
Ich bin in echt 1,97 m groß und die Achterbahn ging in echt nur bis 1,95 m.
Heißt, ich hätte eh schon so eine, sagen wir, Todesangst.
So ein Tunnel einfach, du Barsch.
Ja, aber dann dachte ich mir, man kann doch auch seine Arme hoch machen. Und dann war ich wieder glücklich. Ja, stimmt. Ich glaube, es ist wegen dieser Bügel, die von oben runter klappt, dass das vielleicht nicht genau passt. Hat aber gepasst. Also ging. Aber ich bin schon jemand, der sich dann eher festhält an den Bügeln. Also ich bin kein Armhoch-Typ. Und freue mich aber dann doch auch laut. Also ich schrei dann auch manchmal und hohohoho.
Ja, das ist ein Headpress. So ein bisschen so die typische Break in Akt zwei Momente, wo der Held auf den Drachen springt, diese Poster-Momente.
Der Held von, ich habe How to Train the Dragon nie gesehen, aber wo er auf den Drachen steigt. Wahrscheinlich steigt er auf den Drachen. Wuuuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhchester und jeder kennt diesen ... diese Momente. So, ja, und der Laugh-Attract ist dabei, der beste Freund ist dabei. Der kleine Dicke, der Moment, wo alles gut ist. So bin ich auch in Freizeitparks, aber so bin ich die ganze Zeit. Ich bin immer ein bisschen so aufgeregt, immer in dieser Ha-Ha-Ha-Ha-Stimmung. Auch auf dem Weg nach Hause, im Auto irgendwie auch noch dabei. Nee, da bin ich schlagfertig sauer, weil man steht ja auch auf den Parkplätzen, weil die sind ja nicht so konzipiert, dass man alle irgendwie rausfahren kann, sternförmig, nein, es gibt ja nur einen Ausgang für eine Milliarde Autos, die da stehen, und da war man ja noch irgendwie gefühlt vier Stunden. Freizeitpark ist ja acht Stunden, also ist ja acht Stunden Freizeitpark, davon sind sieben Stunden anstehen, eine Stunde Spaß, und dann ist vier Stunden draußen am Parkplatz stehen, weil man halt irgendwie noch raus muss.
Aber da ist ja noch ein bisschen Popcorn übrig, oder?
Da war noch ein bisschen Popcorn übrig und diese Äpfel, diese glasierten, großen Äpfel, wo man einmal reinbeißt und denkt, mir wird alles rausfliegen. Ein bis purer Zucker, zweiter bis purer Apfel und du denkst dir, geile Idee. Yes, wer ist darauf gekommen? Geile Idee. Aber ich war mal eine Woche, ich glaube ein oder zwei Wochen lang auf einem Campingplatz im Urlaub, der an einen Freizeitpark angeschlossen war. Welcher Freizeitpark denn? Irgendwo in Holland. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wo das war. Efteling. Keine Ahnung. Aber das Geile war, dadurch, dass du halt zwei Wochen auf dem Campingplatz warst, konntest du durchgehend in diesen Freizeitpark gehen. Konstant. Das heißt, du konntest aufwachen und in diesen Freizeitpark gehen, sofort.
Und dadurch, dass ich da halt jeden Tag war, habe ich den irgendwann so gut gekannt, dass ich mich da wirklich zu Hause gefühlt habe. Ich habe jeden Tag die Hans-Glock-Zaubershow gesehen, jeden Tag. Hans Glock hat da die Zaubershow gemacht, eine relativ kleine Bühne, jeden Tag habe ich die Zaubershow gesehen, zusammen mit meinem Onkel. Wir haben uns dann immer so ganz linksaußen hingesetzt in den Publikumsraum, damit wir möglichst hinter die Kulissen sehen können. Und am Ende der Woche hatten wir jeden Zaubertrick entschlüsselt, konnten jeden Zauberspruch sagen, so hat er es gemacht, weil wir immer genau, achte du auf das, ich achte auf die Assistentin, achte auf ihren rechten Arm und wir konnten immer genau darauf achten. Und das konnte ihr an der Rezeption, an der Informationsschalter sagen und dann habt ihr ein Jahr lang nochmal freien Eindruck bekommen im Freizeitpark. Genau, weil wir es gelöst haben. Und du hast gesagt, I don't care for this shit, ich bin durch mit diesem Freizeitpark. Ich habe es geschafft, danach einfach zu Hans Glock gehen und als Autogramm und übrigens, ich habe sie gelöst. Und das war grossartig und dann irgendwann kannte man den auch so gut, es gab so eine Wildwasserbahn, da war dann auch so gross, ging ins Wasserbecken und ein großer Schwall Wasser und wir wussten schon, wo dieser Schwall Wasser sein wird, deswegen haben wir uns immer da hingestellt, damit die Leute denken, da ist sicher und wir wussten immer genau, wann die Wildwasserbahn kam, so dass wildwasserbahn, das ist auch die wildwasserbahn, die wildwasserbahn, wasser ist nicht der spaß daran, doch klar, das wild, wildwasserbahn, wild ist auch die wilde maus. Wildwasserbahn. Wildwasserbahn. Die Wildwasserbahn. Und dann wussten wir immer genau, wann die Wildwasserbahn kam. Und dann konnten wir kurz sofort zur Seite gehen, so dass unsere ganzen nichtsahnenden Opfer dann da standen und nass verspritzt wurden. Oh mein Gott. Und wir haben uns gelacht, wir haben ha ha ha gesagt. Und die Kamera zoomt so ganz schnell raus und sieht so, und Himmel irgendwie der lustigste Film. Freizeitpark Henner oder sowas. Oh Gott, oh Gott. Und grossartig. Aber meinst du nicht, Phantasialand fehlt so ein Maskottchen irgendwie? Fanti. Fanta? Fanta. Fanta oder Papagei. Oder Phantasia. So eine schöne, so eine riesengroße Elfin oder sowas. Du brauchst schon was Cooles. Du brauchst so einen Papagei mit so einer Sonnenbrille, der dann irgendwie so ... Oder so eine Maus mit so großen Ohren. Eine schwarze Maus mit großen Ohren. Eine schwarze Maus? Ja, mit schwarzer Sonnenbrille. Ach so. Aber hat Mickey Maus eine Mütze auf? Nein, nein, nein, hat Mickey Maus eine Müt auf? Schon, oder? Man könnte über Mickey Mouse reden, indem man automatisch die Stimme annimmt. Oder er hat die schwarze Ohren. Ich bin ganz ehrlich, dem Phantasm fehlt kein Maskottchen. Nee. Ich finde, also, so ein bisschen so ein ... was es zusammenfasst. Weil es ist zu wenig Fantasy, es ist zu wenig ... es versucht an manchen Ecken Europapark zu sein. Dann gibt es Mexiko, aber das Afrikaland. Ja, aber das brauche ich einfach. Ich will nicht in den Freizeitpark gehen, ich will Erbrochenes auf dem Boden mit Popcorn drin sehen, ich will irgendwie einmal eine Stunde lang anstehen, ich will eine Rutsche runterrutschen und ich will irgendwie so einen kurz vor dem Hitzeschock stehenden Studenten sehen, der in einem viel zu grossen Kostüm irgendwie über so einen Platz wankt und von Kindern angegriffen wird. Das sind die drei Dinge, die ich sehen will. Ich glaube, ich dachte, wie gern ich darin arbeiten würde in diesem Freizeitpark. Ja? Ja, das ist, glaube ich, der schlimmste Job der Welt. Nee, und zwar würde ich gerne, weil die werden auch immer angezogen. Da waren so ein paar Leute, die sind in unserem Alter auch, und die haben dann zum Beispiel bei der Black Mamba in der Achterbahn gearbeitet.
Und dann haben die so Afrika-Klamotten angekommen.
Oder dann kam es dieses Weltwasserbahn im Mexikoland und dann hatte der so einen grossen Poncho an.
Oder die so ganz süße Strumpfhosen und so grüne Röckchen, peter-peter-pan-artig, wie so Mützen in der Fantasy-Welt, wo ich dachte, ja, das hätte ich auch gerne an und würde dann so immer gucken, ob die Bügel fest sind. Das finde ich für so eine Woche mal mega, mega coolere Freizeit. Du, ich glaube, mit unseren Verbindungen könnten wir das schaffen, dass du mal eine Woche lang Praktikum im Phantasialand machst. Ich würde wahnsinnig gern, es kam sogar zu mir klar. Habe ich nicht ganz genau mitbekommen, da war so eine Jungsgruppe,
ähm, und dann kamen plötzlich so ganz viele Leute mit Walkie-Talkies an, so Parkmitarbeiter, aber schon so die next-level-Parkmitarbeiter. Aber so undercover, die keine Uniform haben. Doch, es waren erst die mit den Phantasialand-Jacken. Ja. Auch die Frage, wo gibt's diese Jacken? Naja, weil ich glaube, wenn man diese Jacke hat, kommt man einfach rein. Oder so oh ja. Oder so ein Klemmbrett und so eine Warenweste, da kommt man glaube ich auch rein. Ja, oder halt diese grünen Strumpfhosen von dem Elfenland. So ein blasses, ganz blass geschminktes Gesicht, so einen schockierten Ausdruck und dann so eine Warenweste, so eine TÜV-Warenweste und so ein Klemmbrett. Ich glaube, da kommt man in jeden Freitagpark rein. So was wie, stimmt, fuck, heute war der Inspektionstermin, fuck, die Black Mamba. Und dann war da aber jemand bei, der wirkte fast wie so ein Parkbilder, so ein langer, schöner, schwarzer Mantel, dann so Walkie-Talkie aber drin, aber war auf jeden Fall Teil von diesen Mitarbeitern. Und dann war ich das spannend, weil diese Jungsgruppe, die wurde dann von denen belagert, ich dachte, die hätten Mist gebaut. Und dann bin ich zu denen hingegangen und habe geguckt, was habe ich denn gemacht, dass ihr jetzt hier so viele Parkmitarbeiter auf euch zieht. Und dann meinten die, nee, nee, nee, einer von den Jungs hat nur in der Wildwasserbahn ins Wasser gespuckt, woraufhin ein Mann einer anderen Familie gesagt hat, boah, ihr Zigeuner. Und manche von denen waren auch mit Migrationshintergrund oder sowas.
Also war schon ein bisschen so ein racist Slur.
Und dann haben die sich geärgert darüber,
das heißt gesagt, und dann hat der andere Mann einen von den Jungs angespuckt ins Gesicht.
Und dann haben die tatsächlich
freien Eintritt bekommen, nochmal.
Und dann haben die sich gefreut, diese Jungsgruppe,
und dann haben sie sich aufgelöst.
Und ich dachte mir, wie kam es jetzt dazu? Was für eine Reihe von Ereignissen. Ich sass dann daneben mit meinem Slush-Eis und dachte mir, was habe ich denn jetzt gerade beobachtet. Mit einem Sherlock-Moment und so, aha, so ist das gespielt. Ich habe mich schon gefreut, dass ich gefragt habe, was die gemacht haben, weil das ist spannend. Also wie kam es zu den ganzen Ereignissen? Die wurden angespuckt, in Zeiten von Corona natürlich furchtbar, wirklich, also unabhängig von diesem eh schon maximal furchtbaren racist Slur. Ja, ja, ja. Aber wie schlimm ist es wirklich, in das Wasser zu spucken? Das fanden die nicht so schlimm, das ist nicht so schlimm, dafür haben die keinen Ärger bekommen. Dafür hat nur der andere Wildwasserbahnbefahrer den angespuckt. Okay, na ja. Und so haben die jetzt wahrscheinlich noch mal, haben die freien Eintritt bekommen, haben sich alle wahnsinnig gefreut und sind alle auseinandergegangen. Und der Moment ist wie nie passiert, hat sich einfach auf dem Moment so aufgelöst. Ja, wie so ein ganz nebligger Flashmob einfach. Man sah den Moment wegfliegen. Da dachte ich mir, ja, das ist das Phantasialand. Wahrscheinlich sind das alles Schauspieler, die dafür sorgen, dass du ihnen jetzt in dem Podcast erzählst, was dir passiert ist einfach. So, das ist die eigentliche Magie. Nicht die ganzen Elfen und Zauberer, sondern dass da irgendwie immer jemand irgendwo gerettet werden muss. Aber das dachte ich mir bei Westworld schon die ganze Zeit. Bei Westworld hat er nicht nur einen mega geilen, Michael Crichton hat das ja geschrieben, der Jurassic Park Guy, der hat ja nicht nur einen Park erfunden, der mega cool ist, wenn man Leute umbringen kann, das sind dann nur so AIs oder sowas, mit denen du dich verlieben kannst oder mit, das ist ja zu krasser AIs halt. Nein, er hätte auch einen Park erfunden, der rollenspielmäßig funktioniert. Und das habe ich auch noch nicht gesehen. Das gibt es ja auch noch nicht mal. Ich brauche diesen AI-Aspekt gar nicht. Aber in einen Park zu gehen, wo einfach ein großes Wild-West-Areal ist, wo es verschiedene Abenteuer gibt, wo alle Leute Schauspieler sind, die irgendwelchen Storylines nachgehen, Storylines zugeteilt werden, und du kannst zu irgendwem beliebigen gehen und machst dann da mit und versuchst irgendwie ein Rätsel zu lösen oder sowas, das ist doch mal geil. Ist halt schwierig, ob so eine ganze Familie irgendwie mit vierjährigem Kind und pubertierendem Sohn, ob die alle in der Rolle bleiben können.
Ob man da wirklich sagt, wir sind jetzt hier eine Familie aus Kansas, wir sind hierher gekommen, gerade auf dem Planwagen. Nach Recklinghausen, wo der Park dann eröffnet wurde. Wir sind jetzt auf der Suche nach dem Ticketstand für die Rodeo-Bahn, weil wir ... So die Frage, wenn dann irgendwann so ... Wenn dann plötzlich das Kind sich irgendwie das Knie verletzt oder so, das Bein verdreht. So die Frage, wann es dann Spielstopp ist. Oder wann der Schauspieler aus dem so ... Nee, was sollen wir machen, dann lassen wir ihn liegen, wir müssen weiter, der nächste ist das Ziel ist drei Tage mehr von uns entfernt. So, ist die Frage, wann das auch einfach nicht mehr lustig ist, weil das Kind wirklich wehgetan hat. Könnten Sie bitte nicht spucken. Corona. Warum tragen Sie keine Maske ein? Die aktuelle Situation ist schwierig. Das ist wirklich schwierig. Ja, das ist ja genauso, wie ich mal auf so einem Mittelalter-Fantasy-Lab war. Mit der Sonnencreme. Und halt Sonnencreme vergessen hatte und niemanden fragen konnte, ob ich mir die Sonnencreme ausleihen kann. Unangenehm. Weil dafür gibt es halt keine Worte in einem mittelalterlichen Setting, so ist halt schwierig. Und dann halt Zahnbürste und so. Ach, heute ist so warm, die Sonne brennt einem förmlich im Gesicht, findest du nicht?
Ja.
Hättest du vielleicht etwas?
Rollenspiel ist normales Sprechen mit ein bisschen mehr Pausen dazwischen.
Ja, und lauter.
Ja, müsste man nichts, man müsste was erfinden, findest du nicht, gegen dieses Schmerzen?
Für eine solche alchemistische Tinktur würde man einiges an Gold-Dukaten bekommen, da bin ich mir sicher. Hast du schon eine Idee, wie du dieses Vorhaben in die Tat umsetzen willst? Nun, wenn die Sterne richtig stehen und die Götter mir heult sind und meine Fähigkeiten mit dem Rührstab behende genug sind, dann könnte ich im nächsten Mond,
beim Mond scheinen und beim drehen Sonnenlauf, vielleicht meinem Ziel näher kommen.
Nee, im Ernst, hast du vielleicht etwas in deinem Beutel dabei?
Die Hunden greifen an!
Was, oh Gott!
Oh, Schwerter gezückt, Brüder und Schwestern! Wer stösst dieses Signal ins Horn, was hat es zu bedeuten? Scheiße. Rückzug! Meine Tochter, der Lehrer meiner Tochter gerade angerufen. Und was sagt er? Es ist wirklich so. Es ist wirklich so auf Laabs. Ja, wie scheiße ist das denn? Es ist genau so, man versucht, um irgendwas herumzureden. Aber man kann immer so mit den Unterarmen X machen, dann ist man kurz aus der Rolle. Ah, das ist das Safety-Word. Das ist das Safety-Word, wenn angenommen jemand putzt sich gerade die Zähne und man sagt, oh, was ist das denn für eine merkwürdige Apparatur,
die ihr da zwischen eure Kauriemen schiebt, edler Rittersmann.
Ich kann das so machen.
Und dann machst du einen X, was schwierig ist, wenn du deine Zähne putzt.
Und dann kannst du nicht kurz sagen, nee, im Ernst, Paul,
ich muss kurz meine Zähne putzen. Warum kann man das nicht einfach sagen?
Naja, weil es ist halt, guck mal, genau diese Probleme
wirst du vor deinem Westernpark auch haben, wo man sagt, warum kann man es nicht einfach sagen, warum müssen wir unser Geld umtauschen, warum kann man nicht einfach sagen, Entschuldigung, meine Tochter ist allergisch gegen Lachs, ist da Lachs drin? So, schwierig. Das fand ich jedenfalls, also und dann ganz toll, wenn der Packer nur bis 18 Uhr auf und dann beginnt überall im Park die gleiche Musik, so eine Wir sehen uns bis zum nächsten Mal Musik, was ich auch aus dem Hansapark kenne, ganz, ganz toll, da läuft irgendwie so eine eigens komponierte Playlist ab und dann, ich fand das so schön, dann geht langsam die Sonne über den Park unter ... Ah, ah, ah, die letzten Schreie von irgendwelchen Freefall-Towern. Die Leute spucken immerhin. Und manchmal habe ich mich auch so ... Ich war ja ein großer Rollercoaster-Tycoon-Fan. Immer Rollercoaster-Tycoon gebaut, meine eigenen Parks gebaut und so was. Und man kennt es ja, dass man dann irgendwann auf diese Männchen klickt, und dann haben die so Gedanken, wie zum Beispiel, oh, Woodwind 42 sieht mir zu aufregend aus, diese Bahn, weißt du, dann haben die immer so Gedanken zu irgendwelchen Fahrgeschäften und ich habe mich wirklich manchmal, habe ich mich beobachtet, wenn ich genau diese Gedanken hatte, weil ich habe immer sehr einfache Gedanken, diese Menschen. Oder du denkst dir gerade, klickt er gerade auf mich drauf? Bin ich jetzt dran, muss ich jetzt was denken? Das habe ich auch gedacht. Ich habe vor allem gedacht, diese Menschen haben exakt realistische Gedanken. Die sind nicht vereinfacht worden, weil das Spiel auch einfach eine Vereinfachung ist. Das ist eine super abstrakte Realität. Nein, ich bin genauso im Freizeitpark. Ich gucke mir nach der Wand und sage mir, oh. Die Schlange für die wilde Maus ist mir zu lang. Ja, die Schlange für wilde Maus zwei ist mir zu lang. Weil meine Hausfrau sich auf zwei geklickt hat. 30 Euro Eintritt sind ganz schön viel. Ja. Ich wünschte, hier gäbe es eine Toilette. Der Park ist sehr verschmutzt. Ich finde mein Auto nicht mehr. Ich weiß nicht, wo ich geparkt habe. Ich weiß nicht. Aber ich hab mir nicht immer so gedacht, wow, Tharon sieht mir so aufregend aus.
Und man kommt auch immer raus aus der Achterbahn und denkt mir, wow, das war aber toll.
Da bin ich ganz basic Gedanken und dann zack, Plan rausgeholt und dann wird schön erstmal wieder gegrübelt, Augen zusammengekniffen. Also der Übergang von Strahlen, ja genau zu und dann Augen stutzend, Augen zusammengezogen, Augenbrauen hochgezogen, in den Parkplan guckend und dann nächste Artikel rausruhen, da bin ich sehr schneller übergang immer. Ja, so Feedback, was denken Sie gerade? Ich bin übrigens auch gerade in einem Feedback-Loop, sage ich mal und so, ich glaube, ich bin auf einen Internetscam reingefallen. Vielleicht ist es der beste Internetscam aller, oder ist es wirklich ein echter Fehler passiert, weil ich bin ja Benutzer des US-amerikanischen iTunes-Stores. Wie ich auch. Und es ist gar nicht so leicht, dafür Guthaben zu bekommen. Man muss sich nämlich dann immer Gift-Cards kaufen, und dann kann man den Code eingeben. Genau, du brauchst die US-Gutscheine quasi. Genau, du brauchst die US-Gutscheine und dann gibt es so Services im Internet, dass du dir die US-Gutscheine
bestellen kannst. Ich finde,
irgendwann muss auch iTunes sagen, es gibt dieses
System, dieses aufwendige System, ihr könnt
uns eh überlisten, wir können da nichts gegen machen,
ladet es einfach mit euren deutschen Kritikarten
auf, komm. Ja, das ist doch wieder so Steuersachen
oder so. Ach so.
Und deswegen, und es ist halt eine schäbige
Seite so und du überweist da halt irgendwie dann so 100 Dollar hin oder so und kriegst dann halt einen Tag später so ein abfotografiertes Bild von so einem iTunes-Gutschein, wo du auch nicht weißt, wo, wie werden die hergestellt, was sind das für Leute? So sind auch so Kratzspuren drauf? Ja, wirklich, jemand hat das abgeknibbelt, ein Foto davon gemacht, ich weiß nicht, ob das legal ist, ob man das darf oder nicht, aber es ist schon zwielichtig.
Aber ich gebe dem Internet erstmal eine Chance.
Ich sage, ja, okay, da versucht jemand irgendwie ein geiles Internetbusiness aufzubauen, irgendwie, ich unterstütze das erstmal. Und dieses Gutschein-Ding hat immer funktioniert. Das ist kein geiles Internetbusiness. Das sind ja klar, das sind junge Leute. Er kauft Karten, iTunes-Gutschein im Supermarkt bei Target,
irgendwo an einer Kasse,
hebelt die auf mit seinem Penny-Stück, macht schäbige Fotos mit seinem Nokia 299-30 und macht die ins Internet für dich. Ja, das ist der neue Steve Jobs. So fängt das an, Stefan. Nein, du musst die Träumer, die Innovatoren auch mal unterstützen irgendwie. Guter Standpunkt für die Geschichte, die jetzt kommt. So, und ich habe da mal so ein paar kleine Gutscheine gekauft und es hat immer gut funktioniert. Und jetzt hast du die 20.000. Und jetzt habe ich halt mal einen saftigen Betrag, weil das ist halt nervig. Dann dachte ich mir, jetzt hole ich mir einmal Guthaben, dann habe ich erst mal ein Jahr, kann ich mir Serien kaufen oder so. Wie viel hast du dir geholt? Und jetzt habe ich mir halt einen dickeren Fisch geangelt. Naja, also es ist jetzt, ich sag mal, wir sind nicht im Bereich deines Parfümflakons. Naja, es ist 150 Dollar. Ach so. Das war nicht so unfassbar viel, aber wenn man sich einfach mal denkt, so okay, das gebe ich ungefähr im Jahr für Medien aus auf iTunes, hole ich mir das einfach mal. Das sind drei Serien oder sowas, das finde ich viel. Ja, na ja, ungefähr sowas. Und jetzt habe ich das bestellt und es kam keine Mail zurück. Geld überwiesen, keine Mail kam zurück. Und vor allem da kann man auch bei Skype anrufen, die haben auch einen Skype-Call. Und so weit bin ich jetzt noch nicht und ich werde jetzt heute Abend mal bei, kommen meinen ganzen Mut zusammen. Rufst du mal jetzt an. Nein, das kannst du nicht machen. Wir rufen da jetzt an.
Mein ganzes, ich habe hier leider kein Internet, das ist das Problem an unseren ganzen Späßen.
Du hast immer so tolle Ideen, die wir in unserem Podcast nach vorne kicken würden. Also ich versuch's.
Ich versuch's halt immer wieder und du blockst das ab. Es scheitert leider immer wieder daran,
dass ich, naja, obwohl ich kann es über mein iPhone machen, aber es ist einfach schwierig.
Das ist jetzt befriedigend für die Zuschauer. Es würde dann doch irgendwie gehen, aber wir machen es trotzdem nicht.
Obwohl es, okay, ich kann das machen, ich weiß nicht, ob das...
So, rufen wir jetzt mal an.
Also, aber was wollen wir denn sagen? What's worth your fucking money? Willst du direkt krass einsteigen?
Weil es ist ja, machen wir uns nichts vor, es ist irgendwie so ein 16-Jährjähriger, der bei target Gutscheine kauft und ins Internet schon mehr Geld stellt. Also, weil du zahlst ja nicht 150 Euro. Das ist der Kontakt, ich sag's vielleicht lieber nicht, aber du kannst ja einfach mal sagen, was diese Firma sich als Icon ausgedacht hat. Diese Maus, ich weiß nicht, wie die heißt, ehrlich gesagt. So, jetzt kann ich ja mal anrufen. Ich rufe jetzt mal auf Skype an. Ja, please give a message receive the email. So I was wondering, because I already bought some gift cards, but the email always arrived on time, but now it didn't.
So could you could you say something?
Because I wanted to watch The Outsider. it was on Sky, but it vanished on Sky. And then I didn't know where to watch it. So maybe you could answer today, because I already bought the first two episodes with my remaining money on my account, and it's a very exciting show. So I don't know what's going on now with the murder. Okay, thank you. Okay. Also auch gut für alle, die sich immer gefragt haben, ist das unser Spaß Englisch? Nein, das ist unser Ernst. Dann das Part eins, Part zwei, mir gefällt sehr, wie pragmatisch du auf eine Antwort auch immer gewartet hast. Also erstmal schön die Fakten dargelegt, aber dann auch immer ein bisschen so immer zwischendurch vergessen, dass man gerade mit einer Voicemail spricht. Ich überlege gerade, ich hätte vielleicht meine E-Mail-Adresse nennen sollen. Du hättest irgendwas damit nennen sollen.
Wenn die wissen, wer ich bin ... Die kennen nur meinen ...
Oh Gott, ich darf meinen ...
Ich würde so gerne meinen Skype-Account-Namen nennen,
weil der so herrlich, herrlich irre ist.
Aber ich kann es nicht, weil ich sonst natürlich Anfragen bekomme.
Aber es ist immer so peinlich, hier unter meinem Namen steht es.
Ja, den kennen wir.
Es ist immer so peinlich, wenn ich irgendwie meinen Skype-Namen rausgeben muss, weil das ist wirklich ein Skype-Name, den habe ich mit 14 wirklich angelegt, ein Skype-Name, in dem zwei Umlaute sind, die beide nicht als Umlaute geschrieben werden, sondern als A, E und es ist unglaublich umständlich. Ist das doch ein peinlicher Reim? Es ist ein peinlicher Reim. Es ist ein Tier. Nichts daran ist schön.
Nichts daran ist schön, es ist ein Tier involviert.
Und immer wenn du den Namen durchgeben musst, ist schön, es ist ein Tier involviert.
Und immer wenn du den Namen durchgeben musst, ist es, sagen wir jetzt mal, Polar-Bär muss immer Polar-Bär-Bayer mit A-E.
Und der andere denkt sich schon irgendwie hier, keine Ahnung, von Tele 5 oder so hier der neue Nachwuchs da will eine eigene Late-Night.
Ich würde gerne drüber reden, ich würde gerne drüber reden, weil es klingt für mich, es ist auch eine Assoziation Flat-Earther irgendwie. Weil, oder zumindest Verschwörungstheoretiker. Also so ein Titel ... Okay, Achtung, Quiz. Du gibst jetzt drei Tipps zu dem Namen, und falls es jemand tatsächlich schafft, mir unter diesem Namen eine Nachricht zu schicken, kriegt der heiße Gewinner die erste Nachricht, die ich kriege, gewinnt mit, kriegt ein T-Shirt und kostenlose Tickets zu einer Live-Show, wo ihr möchtet, wo es noch Tickets gibt. Hier sind die drei Tipps für meinen peinlichen Skype-Namen, den ich mit 14 Jahren gemacht habe.
Aber bitte jetzt nicht so einfache Tipps.
Vor allem, vielleicht findet man das einfach über meinen Namen. Oh Gott, bin ich bescheuert. Nee, ich glaube nicht. Das findet man nicht über den Namen. Okay. Erster Tipp. Es sind zwei sich reimende Wörter. Zweiter Tipp. Das zweite Wort ist ein flauschiges, befälltes Tier. Dritter Tipp. Du musst schon was über das erste Wort sagen, sonst hat man gar keine Chance. Ja genau, das zweite Wort ist das erste Wort und mein dritter Tipp lautet, ich habe auch keine Ahnung, was das genau ist.
Ja, ja, was ist denn so?
Ist das eine gute Quizshow, ist das ein Format Tele 5? Hört hier noch irgendjemand zu eigentlich?
Drei Satte Stunden.
Stellt euch Günther ja auch vor so, ja, die vierte Antwort, ja, keine Ahnung, halt ein Wortspiel, D, pff, was ist es denn, keine Ahnung, man schaut dem Moderator zu, wie er sich die Frage on the fly überlegt.
Und die 100.000-Euro-Frage, wer, nee, nee, wie, nee, in welchem Jahr, nee, welches Land hat im Jahr. Es ist. Nein, sag mal, ich. Der dritte Tipp ist, es ist ein Adjektiv, das mit einem Ort beziehungsweise zu tun hat. Okay, ich freue mich auf eure Nachrichten. Ich bin sehr, sehr gespannt. Es könnte sein, dass das die dümmste Idee aller Zeiten war, weil ich diesen Skype-Account tatsächlich benutze regelmäßig. Aber ja, viel Erfolg auf jeden Fall an euch. Wir wollen ja die Detektive unter euch belohnen. Und ja, viel Erfolg. Okay, und jetzt ist die Frage, bist du doch eingefallen oder nicht? Vor allem, ich bin ja auch, also jetzt sind wir mal ganz ehrlich, ich bin ja auch jemand, der einfach auch, also ich drücke es mal so positiv wie möglich aus, ich bin ein guter Verlierer. Vollidiot, achso. Naja, so kommen wir gleich. Ich bin ein guter Verlierer, wenn mich jemand erfolgreich betrübt, dann nehme ich das so hin. Ich werde da jetzt nicht irgendwie Geld zurückfordern oder meinen Anwalt einschalten. Hast du das über Paypal überwiesen? Ja. Da kannst du ganz einfach ... Nee, du hast wahrscheinlich ... Doch, das ist über Kauverschutz gesichert. Ja, aber sind wir mal ehrlich, das werde ich nicht machen. Warum eigentlich? Ich werde das nicht machen. Ein Knopfdruck ist nicht so viel. Ich werde das nicht machen, Stefan. Ich werde das nicht machen, Stefan. Du gönnst Jerry der Maus das Geld. Stefan, ich werde das nicht machen. Ja, das hast du meine ich schon mal erwähnt gerade. Wenn ich im Restaurant ein Essen bestelle und der Kellner kommt auf mich zu, lässt das Essen vor meinen Augen auf den Boden fallen, nimmt das Essen mit der Hand vom Boden auf, legt es auf meinen Teller, der wieder runterfällt, der noch mal runterfällt, der Teller zerschellt, er nimmt die grösste Scherbe, nimmt das restliche Essen noch mit Scherben drin in die Hand, schmiert das Essen auf diese Scherbe und serviert es mir. Ich würde es ohne einen Kommentar essen und einen schönen Abend haben, nur nach Hause zu gehen. Vielen Dank, danke schön. Ich würde mich nicht beschweren, ich würde mein Geld nicht zurückfordern, ich würde dieses Restaurant wieder aufsuchen. Ich würde es empfehlen, wenn jemand fragt, ich war gestern gut essen, ich würde nicht von der negativen Erfahrung berichten. Ja, wenn die Person, mit der ich essen gefragt, wie war dein Essen, würde ich sagen, fantastisch, absolut fantastisch. Weil alles andere löst Fragen aus. Also genau so bin ich auch. Wie beschreibt man solche Menschen? Konfliktscheu als fuck. Stimmt schon, ja, die deutsche Sprache hat schon was zu bieten, hat noch ein paar Pfeile im Köcher. Die ist vor allem nicht schön und vielseitig. Devot ist Devot ein Wort. Ja, aber das ist ja... Devot ist, man macht das, was andere einem sagen. Ja, das ist gar nicht mal Devot. Also ich meine, das erfordert auch schon einen gewissen Mut und so, auch eine gewisse Energie. Ja, auch so, Devot ist für mich so passiv. Du bist ja sehr aktiv daran beteiligt in dieser Situation und aktiv treibst du ja nach vorne, dass es eine konfliktlose Situation, eine harmonievolle Situation bleibt. Was hältst du von selbstlos? Ich würde bei dem Wort bleiben, was ich eingangs gesagt habe. Also die erste Sache, die du gesagt hast am Anfang des Meetings, dabei würdest du bleiben, was wir jetzt die letzten 20 Minuten besprochen haben. Als Feedback, das würdest du ignorieren. Du würdest trotzdem noch bei dem bleiben, dass du am Anfang ... Ich hab gesagt, das Meeting brauchen wir auch nicht. Ich weiß nicht, dass eine Idee das war. Konfliktscheu finde ich nämlich gut. Dann halten wir mal konfliktscheu, selbstlos und devot fest. Oh Gott, nein. Und dann würde ich sagen, machen wir morgen einfach 15 Uhr noch mal ein Meeting. Und dann schauen wir noch mal drüber. Hier kann sich ja jeder Gedanken machen, einfach, dass wir bis morgen noch mal ein paar Ideen sammeln. Und dann schauen wir morgen noch mal. Und dann Timebox, da wird es getimeboxed. Zumindest. Genau, wir machen Google Doc auf. Timeboxen heißt ja zumindest, dass es irgendwie auf eine Zeit begrenzt ist. Wir timeen heißt es mal, sag ich mal, auf drei Stunden. Länger brauchen wir dafür nicht. Und man denkt, oh Gott, noch mal drei Stunden. Scheiße. Weil Timeboxen heißt ja auch, es dauert auf jeden Fall so lange, auch wenn man schon nach Vorrei durch ist. Ja, absolut. Ich finde Konflikt sehr gut. Vor allem, es ist ja nicht nur dem Konflikt aus dem Weg gehen, es ist ja auch jeder anderen Form von Interaktion danach aus dem Weg gehen.
Also du hast ja auch gesagt, wenn eine Person fragt, wie es war, sagst du fantastisch, weil du ja auch keinen Bock hast auf, naja, ist auch so dieses amerikanische, was man im Englischen-Deutschen nennt, dieses Hey, how are you, ist eine Begrüssung, es ist keine Frage, wie es dir geht. auch im deutschen wenn du sagstst, wie geht's, selten hört man jemanden, der sagt, wenn du so fragst, wenn du so fragst, nee, gar nicht gut. Und so der andere, so der Nachbar, der schon das Fahrrad in der Hand hat und irgendwie losfahren will und fragt so, hey Stefan, wie geht's und man sagt so und stellt man seine Einkäufe ab und sagt erstmal, verschränkt die Arme und sagt, weißt du was? Ganz, gar nicht gut. Gar nicht gut. Und der andere denkt so, so halb schon losgefahren, hätte schon so die Pedale richtig, da sind nur noch einen Schritt benötigt, um davon zu brausen. Ja. Hängt noch so in der Luft, weil, und das macht niemand, weil diese Frage ist dann nicht dafür vorgesehen, dass man ernsthaft darauf antwortet. Und deswegen meine ich, man sagt selten, ach nee, weißt du, weil man auch dem macht keinen Bock auf dich zu erklären. Absolut, also da müsste man mir wirklich viel Geld bieten, das ist unvorstellbar, auch so die Vorstellung, man nimmt irgendeine Dienstleistung in Empfang oder irgendwie sowas, man, habe ich jetzt noch nie gemacht, aber man kriegt eine Massage oder so und dann nach einer Stunde sagt man, hat es ihm gefallen? Nö, absolut unvorstellbar, absolut. Da könnte jemand wirklich mit einem Holzstock eine Stunde lang auf mich einschlagen. Ich war gerade beim Friseur und am Ende kriegt man ja immer den, ja. Und hat es ihm gefallen? Ja, fantastisch, grossartig. Und man robbt auf dem Boden aus dem Massageladen draus. Das war richtig gut. Ich würde sogar so Augment Smalltalk noch machen.
Warum haben Sie das denn gelernt?
Da hat man das, kann man das einfach
und dann tot.
Blutergüsse haben ihn dahingerafft, innere Blutungen.
Ich war gleich beim Friseur und am Ende kriegt man dann den Spiegel.
Wie oft bist du mittlerweile eigentlich beim Friseur?
Alle vier Wochen.
Stefan.
Alle vier Wochen ist das Problem. Und jedes Mal siehst du komplett neu aus. Nein. Du bist gerade wie in so einer Charakterauswahl, wo man so sip, sip, sip, und hier alles komplett blondiert hat. Aber da kriegst du halt, ja genau, oh. Ja, kennst du das, wenn man im Spiel sehr viele Sidequests gemacht hat und sich dann einfach mal gehen lässt. Ja. So, dann kann man auch mal in die Läden gehen, die man geskippt hat, die Kostümläden. So die, wo man sich ein neues Outfit, wo man sich das ganze Outfit kaufen kann. Vor allem, du trägst auch die Frisur, es gäbe eine andere Frisur, die plus drei Stärke gibt, aber du hast dich für die Frisur entschieden, die minus zwei Intelligenz gibt, aber die dir besser gefällt. Und damit läufst du rum. Klar. Und natürlich habe ich die Rüstung auch noch an, die mich nicht gut schützt.
Aber die habe ich komplett.
Und die zu Einheit leben schön. Die passt zu deinem Schwert.
Die passt zu meinem Schwert.
Die ist historisch korrekt.
Und dann kriegt man am Ende den Spiegel gezeigt.
Und am Ende kommt immer dann, und gefällt es dir?
Und ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben ...
War ich zu 100 % zufrieden?
Und ich habe noch nie gesagt, nee, gefällt mir nicht. nicht. Was ist das für ein Zeitpunkt in der Dienstleistung, mir zu zeigen, was sie gemacht hat, wie sie die Haare geschnitten hat? Ich glaube, das wäre mal so eine Gameshow, die mich ... Stimmt übrigens, ich bin immer sehr zufrieden. Das wäre mal so eine Gameshow, die mich interessieren würde, dieses Wie weit kann man es treiben? Ich glaube, das ist ein relativ häufiges Verhalten, dass die Leute immer ja sagen, ja, sieht toll aus, egal wie die Frisur war. Und jetzt würde ich gerne eine Gameshow machen, wo du wirklich die Frisur komplett verunstaltest. Und dann einfach zu gucken, wie weit muss man gehen, dass Leute wirklich sagen, nein, es sieht furchtbar aus, wirklich furchtbar aus. Also wirklich noch so eine blaue
Strähne mit reinmachen, von der die Person
nichts gesagt hat. Einfach so,
ja, einfach nur gerne die Spitzen ein bisschen schneiden
und dann einfach direkt den Rasierer
an und dann einfach so die eine
Hälfte gelb, die andere
Hälfte blau färben. Ich würde nicht
sagen, sobald das Färbemittel
rauskommt, völlig in Ordnung.
Ich habe auch so wenig Ahnung vom Friseur Craft, dass ich denke, ja, vielleicht ist es jetzt Teil Und dann ist es auch ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, am Ende des, nee, das ist schon der Ernst. Oh, vor allem das ist mir das schlimmste, ich bin so einer Person mal begegnet. Und zwar war ich mal in einem Zug und es war die Phase, wo ich ein bisschen so eine Starbucks-Phase hatte und wo ich mir immer so schön diesen Chai-Tee. Meine Skinny-Jeans-Starbucks-Phase. Genau, schön mit einem MacBook ein bisschen geblockt irgendwie und dann hatte ich immer schön. Immer an einem Drehbuch und in between Projects. Genau, Between Project hat was in der Pipeline und ich hatte immer schön den Chai Latte Venti, immer schön den richtig großen Humpen, den 0,8er, 0,8er schönen Chai Tee und bin dann in so einen Zug reingegangen und er musste dann so meinen Koffer oben über einem Fahrgast platzieren, irgendwie hochhiefen und hatte währenddessen meinen Chai TTee-Becher so in der Hand. Und dann fährt halt in dem Moment der Zug los. Ich krieg's nicht ganz hin mit meinem Zug und schütte der Person, die neben mir sitzt, den kompletten 0,9er heissen Chai-Tee-Becher einmal komplett über den Körper. Das kann nicht wahr sein. Und weißt du, was die Person gesagt hat? Kein Problem, alles in Ordnung.
Und ich halt so,
oh mein Gott, sorry, es tut mir
so leid, alles so, kein Problem,
überhaupt kein Problem, und schaut zum Fenster raus.
Und ich dachte mir so, was?
Und ich dachte mir wirklich so, ja, exakt
so will ich auch reagieren.
Führen Sie solche Personen.
Es war, ist mal eine ältere Person,
Hemd in die Jeans gesteckt. Mann, ältere Mann. Naja, was heißt älter, halt so 40, so was in die Richtung. Und irgendwie... Schönes Hemd, hast du dich überlegt. Schönes Hemd, sass da, irgendwie flotte Frisur. Eine Flotte Frisur? Nein, normale Frisur, halt irgendwie so ein normaler, halt so wie so ein Papa halt. Was für ein Job? Ach na ja, der wird halt keine Ahnung, irgendwie so Bodenbaustoffprüfer sein. Aber eher Bürojob. Na ja, ich glaube, das ist schon so jemand, der mit so einem gelben Helm auf so einer Baustelle ist und dann mal so auf dem Boden klopft und sagt, ja, hier kann man bauen und dann mal so den Sand nimmt und sagt. So ein Macher aber dann doch. Naja, ich glaube, einer dieser Jobs, von dem einfach niemand weiß, dass er nicht nötig ist, weil da hat schon mal jemand geprüft, ob der Boden, die Baustelle steht ja da schon. Ja, das meine ich nämlich. Aber der kommt nochmal und hat dann so einen Speer und stösst in den Boden und rüttelt dann da so rum und sagt, naja, bisschen grafitlastig ist es schon, aber ich glaube, man kann hier bauen. Und dann sagt der Bauleiter, wunderbar, wir bauen weiter, wir haben jetzt den Bagger schon da, wir hätten eh gebaut.
Ist ja der kleine Bruder mit dem Controller, der nicht angeschlossen ist. So, der einmal den gelben Helm hat und dann losfährt und die Bauarbeiter lachen sich natürlich kaputt und sagt, der ist wieder da. Gesicht Behaarung, ja, nein, nein, oder? Also es klingt echt unscheinend nach glatt rasiert. Nee, nee, nee, es ist ein etwas dünner, kurzer Bart blond.
Oh, ich kann mich an keine Person der Welt so gut erinnern, wie du an diese Person gerade. Ich könnte die Frisur meiner Mutter nicht so gut erinnern. Das hat sich mir ins Gehirn gebrannt, weil vor allem du hast ja so ein Gefühl, ich muss jetzt bestraft werden, so, also du bist ja, ich habe gerade was falsch gemacht, ich will jetzt angeschrien werden, so, es fühlt sich ja noch schlimmer an, wenn die Person einfach sagt, überhaupt kein Problem, kein Ding, und dann hat der selber so mit dem Taschentuch so ein bisschen vom Boden das aufgewischt und so. Oh Gott sei Dank, wenigstens das. Und wirklich, und ich dachte, das darf nicht dein Ernst sein, und es war so furchtbar, dass ich auch wirklich sofort gegangen bin. Ich bin wirklich zwei Wagons weiter und habe dann meinen Koffer geholt, noch mal, als ich ausgestiegen bin. Der lag dann die ganze Fahrt da. Aber das ist auch noch schlimmer. Dann dachte er, hu, wer war der genau, kommt in den Koffer. Entschuldigung, haben Sie Ihren Koffer vergessen? Trieft halt irgendwie Quatsch so an. Quatsch so an und bringt meinen Koffer in den anderen Appell. So, Entschuldigung, Sie haben Ihren Koffer vergessen. Nee, aber auch, jetzt denkt er, hätte ich wenigstens neben ihm setzen können an deinem Platz, weil jetzt denkt er, wow, auch noch umsonst hat es mich getroffen, weil dieser Vollidiot am falschen Platz gestanden hat. Ja, aber ich glaube, exakt so würde ich, weil ich würde doch nicht aus, ich würde doch nicht sagen, aber was fällt Ihnen denn ein? Ich würde einfach sagen, so ey, kein Problem, alles cool, sorry.
Und dann halt einfach beim Bewerbungsgespräch auftauchen oder auf der Baustelle auftauchen.
Die Bauarbeiter lachen mich eh schon aus.
Und wenn ich da jetzt noch irgendwie mit so einem, man sieht halt auch meinen etwas voluminösen Oberkörper, sieht man durch das Hemd.
Ich habe kein Unterhemd an, durch den Chaitee ist jetzt alles durchsichtig und ich komme da an, ja, wird da nichts. Und die Milch da drin, das stinkt doch auch wie scheiße. Ja, wirklich eineinhalb Liter Chai-Tee komplett ergossen. Aber auch, dass er aufs Fenster guckt, finde ich aber auch so eine gute, pragmatische, ja, was soll ich machen, wie ich machen? Wie soll ich das ... Ich würde mich schon aufregen, doch. Aber nicht so, dass der andere sich schlecht fühlt. Ich würde schon sagen, oh fuck, oh nein. Dann würde ich darüber lachen, aber ich würde jetzt schon so ... Oh fuck, nee. Was willst du denn machen? Das ist ein Musgeschick. Da hat niemand Exa gemacht. Aber ich hätte tatsächlich mehr Mitleid mit der Person, als ich mich über mich selber ärgern würde. Also mein Schaden ist ist kleiner, als dass ich mit der Person Mitleid habe, und ich würde sagen, kein Problem, überhaupt kein Problem, alles in Ordnung. Also, ich würde mich eher um die Person kümmern, als um mich selbst. Und dann, ich würde natürlich in mich reinfressen. Du wirst genau, wie er reagieren. Ja. Ja, aber du merkst gerade, was das schlimmste Trauma deiner jüngsten Geschichte ist. Ja, natürlich. Ja, aber dann sei doch nicht so. Na ja, da sind jetzt halt zwei Pluspole aufeinander getroffen, das war halt unglücklich. Aber ich glaube, ja, aber auf der anderen Seite soll man sich so verhalten, wie man selbst behandelt werden wollte oder gerade nicht? Doch, nimmst du nach Kant. Sie ist nach Kant. Nein, aber Kant hat ja ein massives Batterieproblem, weil dann treffen ja immer Plusmenschen auf Plusmenschen. Eigentlich will man ja Plus und Minus, man will ja eigentlich gucken, dass es sich ergänzt. Nein, Kant sagt ja nur, das ganz, ganz stark vereinfacht, dass du so behandelt wirst, wie du gerne behandelt werden wollen würdest. Im schlechteren Deutsch. Ich kann Zitate immer ein bisschen schlechter wiedergeben, als sie eigentlich sind. Es passt schon. Du willst, wenn du ein Pluspol bist, willst du ein Minuspol, also behandelst du Leute, als wärst du ein Minuspol. Also soll ich dann doch Leute ankacken, gegen meine Intuition die Leute anschreien, wenn sie was ... Nee, also, wie gesagt, ich würde sie auch nicht anschreien, aber ich würde zumindest so, ach fuck, nee, jetzt müssen die fünf Stunden nach Hamburg fahren, mit dem Zeug drauf, ehrlich, ach Gott, ja gut, was soll man machen. Aber dann würde ich zumindest darüber lachen und so, und ich glaube, dann ist man zusammen in einem Boot und so. Ja, es stimmt schon, es ist wirklich schlimmer, wenn man für Dinge nicht bestraft wird, so das ist schon clever. Es ist schlimmer, auch anders als von der Gesellschaft vorhergesehen zu reagieren, das ist auch schon schwierig. Ja, aber ich glaube, das ist für, also moralisch gar keine dumme Idee zu sagen, man muss irgendwie büssen und man muss irgendwie die Strafe bekommen und dann geht es einem besser, auch wenn die Strafe natürlich unangenehm ist. Ich erinnere mich zum Beispiel auch noch ganz klar daran, wie ich meinen Mitbewohner und ich war der schlechteste Mitbewohner aller Zeiten, immer noch furchtbarer Mitbewohner, aber ich hatte eine lange Zeit einen Mitbewohner, der hatte sehr, sehr Ich bin so froh, dass wir nicht in den Wege gezogen sind. Das war kurz davor. Wir hatten die Idee, aber haben wir nicht gemacht. Sei froh, weil ich hatte einen Mitbewohner, der so wichtig die Antithese von mir ist und der einfach Stil hat, dem einfach wichtig ist, dass Dinge eine Qualität haben und einen Anspruch haben. Und ich weiß noch, wie ich damals nach Hause gekommen bin und mir gerade beim Lidl die runtergesetzten Halloween-Chicken-Nuggets gekauft habe. Halloween war vorbei, und die Halloween-Chicken-Nuggets, also in
Geisterform, in Kürbisform,
Es war nicht mehr
Bootbell, Bredable Ball?
Nee, genau, es war
Ghost Pumpkin Skeleton,
habe ich gekauft
für einen halben Preis, und ich
brate mir gerade meine Halloween-Chicken-Nuggets,
so das schlechteste Essen, was es
gibt, in der Pfanne an, er kommt nach Hause, ich frage ihn, hey, willst du auch ein paar Halloween-Chicken-Nuggets? Und er hat so ein Sous-Vide-Garer am Start. Ja, und er schaut mich wirklich an mit so einem Blick, so ein, wenn ich verhungern würde, würde ich das nicht essen. Deinen Schmutz will ich gar nicht, ich will gar nicht im selben Raum sein. Griff zu seinem Weinkühlschrank und nahm den Blonde Noir heraus. Und wenn ich mir schön die runtergesetzten Chicken Nuggets reinschiebe, halb abgelaufen. Und der hat sich einmal so richtig gutes Essen gemacht, so richtig so Nudeln, hat irgendwie so am Markt, Wochenmarkt zu Trüffel besorgt und hat sich dann so eine Rahm-Champignon mit Trüffel-Pasta gemacht, so Tagliatelle irgendwie und wirklich alles gut, fantastisch gemacht. Man man hat wirklich angemerkt, für ihn geht es jetzt auch nicht nur ums Essen, sondern auch das Kochen ist Teil des Ganzen, mit einem Glas Weisswein dabei und dann mit Ablöschen und so und wirklich und irgendwie so eine schöne Arie von Puccini irgendwie noch in den Ohren. Das war für ihn sein Abend, er kocht sich jetzt was Feines, er, ist es und geniesst es und geniesst die Zulassung. Das ist alles Teil des Events. Das ist alles Teil des Events und er war so wirklich bei sich, er hat so wirklich gelebt und so ein Ledergürtel und Hemd und alles war halt gestimmt. Und dann war dieses Essen komplett fertig und er richtet das auch wirklich so schön an mit der Soße drüber, Petersilie drüber und alles wunderbar dabei. Und ich komme so rein, der mit mir und er so, komm so an, und ich will was trinken und
komme so an und will mir ein Glas holen und er hatte halt so seinen Teller gestellt auf
so die Ablage und darüber war die Vitrine für die Gläser und ich greife so. dabei und du kommst rein. Hallo, wen haben wir denn da? Kommt er so an und greift so an ihm vorbei an die Vitrine, so ich will kurz ein Glas, mach die Vitrine auf, greift dieses Glas, meine fettigen Stummelfinger können dieses Glas nicht greifen, das Glas fällt und es fällt direkt in seine Nudeln und das Glas geht kaputt in seinen Nudeln. Oh mein Gott. Unrettbar, Glasscherben, alles kaputt und er wirklich schaut dieses Essen an, verzieht keine Miene, nimmt den Teller, schüttet ihn in den Müll. Aber so mit der Gabel, so mit der Gabel in den Müll, komplett alles in den Müll. Reicht einem so ein Kipper? Oder wirklich? Kipper und dann noch mit der Gabel. Dreimal kratzen. Jede Erbse ist vom Teller. Streift er ab in den Müll und mit einer Seelenruhe nimmt er sich einen Toast und schmiert sich einen Toast. Oh, das war so, weil er dann so den Chick-Magnon. Ich dachte, die haben jetzt ihr Revival. Ja, und ich war einfach am Boden zerstört. Allein, wie ruhig er das genommen hat, das hat mich so vernichtet. Also, dass er mich nicht anschreit oder irgendwas auf mich wirft oder mich schlägt oder irgendwie, sondern dass er das so einfach so stolz schreckt. Es trennt euch in gewisser Weise auch mehr, als dass es euch zusammenbringt, weil, also, man weiß ja, dass es ihm gerade was bedeutet hat. Man weiß, dass du gerade was zerstörst, was ihm wichtig war. Und dann finde ich es fast schwierig, weil du weisst ja jetzt, streng genommen hast du jetzt ja Fenster zu seiner Seele geöffnet und weisst ja, was in ihm vorgeht. Ja. Weil du hast ja beobachtet, dass es ihm was bedeutet. In dem Moment, wo er das nicht preisgibt, finde ich, zeigt das, dass so eine krasse Distanz zwischen euch ist. Ja, es zeigt aber auch ein bisschen, dass er gar nicht so davon überrascht ist, dass ich jetzt sein Essen ruiniere. Es ist so... Also das ist so... Haben wir ihn zumindest so ein... Na, null. Gar nichts. So ein kurzes... Gar nichts. Das war wirklich so ein hinnehmen. Nicht mal ein drüber lachen? Nein, gar nicht.
Heute glaube ich, können wir drüber lachen, aber damals halt gar nicht. Und es ist wirklich so, und ich war
wirklich vernichtet, es ist so, wie wenn du so einer Katze auf den
Schwanz steigst und du denkst dir so
um Gottes Willen, ich kann
dir nicht erklären,
ich kann jetzt nichts tun. Doch, ich habe jetzt gelesen,
wie man Katzen angrinst.
Weil Katzen können das Gesicht nicht verchecken
von Menschen. Also wenn du die angrinst, süss, checken die nicht, was wir machen mit unserem Mundwinkel. Katzen lächelst du, ich mach's kurz für dich vor, dann erklär ich's den Hörern, aber so lächeln Katzen. Nee, du hast nicht ganz geguckt, du hast nicht ganz geguckt. Ah, okay, okay. Also, du machst die Augen ganz langsam zu, dann berührt sich das Lied einmal, schließt es ganz, um dann schnell wieder aufzugehen. Ja, genau, das habe ich auch schon mal gehört, dass dieses langsame Zwinkern irgendwie sowas wie Zuneigung bedeutet. Ja, dass wir das Katzen machen, lächeln sie nicht an. Aber geht das als Entschuldigung, wenn du der Katze auf den Schwanz steigst? Ja, aber dann will ich dir mal sehen, wie du dann die Ruhe in dir nimmst, um dann in dem Tempo, weil das ja keine schnelle Geste, so ein Grinsendes schnell gemacht. Ja. So ein Sorry auch, aber so dieses langsame Augen zu kneifen. Oh, das war furchtbar, aber es ist wirklich so, das ist, das sind so die zwei Sachen, erinnere ich mich. Ich habe nichts aus meiner Studienzeit, alles weg, nur die beiden Dinge aus meiner Studienzeit, daran erinnere ich mich noch. Es sind beides Dinge, wo du Leuten massiven Schaden zugefügt hast. Und die, und ich dafür keine Strafe bekommen habe. Und du dafür keine Strafe bekommen hast. Also auf eine Art habe ich ja diese Silent Treatment bekommen. Ich glaube, du kommst mit irrationalem Verhalten nicht, du kommst mit irrationalem Verhalten, was dir spiegelt, dass du irrationales Verhalten an den Tag legst, ist nicht klar. Gefällt mir. Gefällt mir, gute Interpretation. Wahrscheinlich füge ich vielen Menschen ähnlich großen Schaden zu, wenn ich auch das so hinnehme, wenn was passiert. Voll. Habe ich dir schon mal großen Schmerzen zugefügt? Nee. Auch weil du in der Regel derjenige bist, der die Website leuchtet und sowas. Guck mal, aber dann kannst du dich gut fühlen, weil ich scheiße gebaut habe.
Ich hebe mich ja normal auf. Aber wie du mich dann auch kennst in solchen Situationen, ich habe dann schnell ein Humorlevel, weil das bringt auch schnell Distanz. so? Also ich habe schnell dann entwickelt, ich habe die, es gibt keine Aufregung und dann der Galgenhumor, es kommt direkt der Galgenhumor, was aber glaube ich ganz gut ist.
Aber ich habe gerade darüber nachgedacht die ganze Zeit, während du gesagt hast, wie konfliktcheu du bist und ich habe dir das erste Mal sehr vehement zugestimmt, aber es stimmt gar nicht eigentlich. Ich merke gerade, ich fahre sehr viel Fahrrad neuerdings, wohne jetzt ja hier in Ehrenfeld und finde hier ein bisschen fahrradfreundlicher als da, wo ich vorher gewohnt habe und so,
habe ein schönes Fahrrad und jetzt den ganzen Sommer
bin ich langgefahren
durch Ehrenfeld und Köln.
Und es ist schon keine, es ist eine super
fahrradfeindliche Stadt, also super
nervig zu fahren, überall Autos,
überall abbiegende Autos, die einen Scheiss
sich interessieren, überall crowded
Fußwege, die auf die
Fahrradwege ausweichen, teilweise müssen und so weiter. Und ich liebe es, ich liebe es, Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, teilweise müssen usw. Und ich liebe es, ich liebe es, was die Gesellschaft, die Gesellschaft liebt ja Fahrräder, also eigentlich. Fahrräder haben so einen hohen Standpunkt, in Köln nicht, also alles an der Stadtplanung gesagt, kein hoher Standpunkt, aber die Gesellschaft gibt Fahrrädern viele Rechte. Also wenn ein Fußgänger auf den Fahrradweg geht und du klingelst den weg, ist immer ein entschuldigendes, ach ja, sorry, habe ich nicht gesehen. Und ich liebe diesen Hochschlag oder das Fahrradfahrer. Und ich liebe es auch, mich aufzuregen über Menschen, die das nicht sehen. So zu so einem Punkt, dass ich fast so eine Art Stuntfahrer werde. Also Beispiel, da ist immer eine Ausfahrt, wo ich schon weiss, dass da viele Autos immer rauskommen, die die Fahrradweg nicht beachten. Und dann fahr ich da hin und ich hab die Hand an der Bremse. Also es ist so wie jemand, der sich gleich anzündet, weil da so eine Kerze fällt oder so, aber ich hab schon den Anzug an in so Filmen. Man weiss nicht, ob ich mit diesem Anzug an, dass mir nichts passieren kann, mit diesem eingeölten Anzug. Und ich habe quasi die Hand an der Bremse schon, fahre hin und bremse extra spät vor dem Auto. Und springe dann auch noch so ab, wäre alles nicht nötig gewesen. Ah, herrlich. Es war nicht mal knapp. Es ist nie knapp bei mir. Ja. Bei diesen Situationen. Und ich habe bestimmt, wenn ich einmal durch Köln fahre, habe ich bestimmt zu finden so Situationen, wo ich viel zu spät erst bremse oder das viel tragischer mache. Mittlerweile kann ich auch so gut dann so abspringen, dass es so aussieht, als wäre es so eine Vollbremsung gewesen und so. Und reg mich dann auf, schweißt dann die Arme hoch und sagt, kannst du nicht gucken und so. Hab schon so einen Satz mir überlegt, zu Recht. Ich reg mich so gerne darüber auf. Das ist genauso schön, wie wenn jemand, das ist genauso, also eine Berechtigung hat man dazu.
Ja.
Wo hat man die denn schon mal?
Wie so ein Boxsack oder wie so ein Typ, der auf seinem Platz sitzt in der Bahn und du kannst sagen, nee, ist mein Platz. Ja, genau so ist das aber.
Aber wie durchdringst du den Autokäfig? Also bist du dann auch einer, der sagt, jetzt mal runterfahren hier?
Gar nicht.
Also Scheibe runter oder brüllst du dagegen an?
Ich brüll dagegen an.
Ja.
Auch mit dem Wissen, ich mach es ja auch nicht nur für den, das ist ja ein Schauspiel für alle, rung rings und herum. Ja klar. Ich habe heute tatsächlich auch, ganz untypisch eigentlich, aber ich bin über die Straße gegangen in so einer Innenstadt-Straßen-Geflecht-Situation. Ganz viele Läden, Fußgänger laufen auch ab und zu auf der Straße, es ist keine Fußgängerzone, aber man teilt sich so ein bisschen die Umwelt, weil die Fusswege nicht groß genug sind.
Und dann fährt wirklich so ein Auto und ich laufe halt davor und das Auto hubt mich halt laut an und ich gucke halt so im Sinne von Hallo, ich bin hier Fussgänger, ich darf alles. Und dann sagt er halt wirklich, fährt das Fenster runter, weil ich halt wirklich so konfrontativ zu so einem Stop and Talk, zu einem Stop and Argue bereit bin.
Ich biete mich an,
und er fährt da drüber und sagt, das ist ja kein Zeberstreifen.
Und ich kurz ...
Ja, aber ich darf hier trotzdem rübergehen,
als Fussgänger hat man Vorfahrt.
Und er so, nein, warum sollte man als Fussgänger Vorfahrt haben?
Fick dich! Aber die müssen Rücksicht nehmen auf Fussgänger! Und ich war wirklich so, fuck, ich hab die Lautstärke. Lautstärke ist viel zu hoch dafür, dass ich keine Ahnung habe ... Nee, du hast keine Grundlage für Argumente. ... wie die Straßenverkehrsordnung tatsächlich ist, ob Fussgänger auf einer Strasse Vorfahrt haben, ob die einfach gehen dürfen. Aber ich kann mich genauso gut entschuldigen. Wenn ich Situationen habe, wo ich Scheiße baue oder sowas, habe ich sofort immer die Hand hoch, dieses Sorry, das ist mir gerade passiert. Normalerweise, aber ich bin wirklich, sobald ich mal drin bin, dann auch, ja, pass dir mal auf, und dann gehe ich auch schon wieder, weil mir die Argumente ausgehen. Ja, die Argumente gehen auch aus. Und dann, extrem unangenehm, geht auch noch jemand wieder genau neben mir hier ewig lang, der das Ganze mitverfolgt hat. Und ich dachte mir, weiss, kennt er die Strassenverkehrsordnung gut genug, um zu wissen, dass ich ihm unrecht war, ist er auf meiner Seite. Ich wage mal so einen verbrüdernden Blick zur Seite, von ihm kommt nichts. Schämt er sich für mich, dass er Fußgänger ist wie ich, sagt er, ich brauche ein Auto, ich brauche ein Auto. Und dann immer diese weisen Menschen, die dann kurz in sich hineinlachen. Was geht in ihm vor? Er wusste alles. Er wusste alle Argumente für beide Seiten und so. Er wusste alles, er wusste genau Bescheid und ich habe wirklich so versucht, was spiele ich jetzt? Spiele ich jetzt, der Streit nimmt mich noch mit oder spiele ich jetzt, auch den Streit habe ich doch schon vergessen. Ich habe mich für zweiteres entschieden und dann wirklich so ein, ich schaue in die Schaufenster rein, aha, ich habe dann, mich beruhigt das gar nicht mehr. Unfassbar unangenehm, ich kann auch, ich kann das nicht, so streiten und so, dann spontan Argumente finden, nee, das geht nicht. Nee, so spontan auch nicht, ich bin dann auch zu aufbrausend und so und dann bestellt sich meine Stimme und ich, was ich auch manchmal mache, ist, ich bin, also ich fahre auch manchmal auf der falschen Seite Fahrrad, wenn es der schnellere Weg ist, so. Wenn es ein Riesenaufwand jetzt wäre, über die andere Strassenseite zu fahren. Und dann kommen mir manchmal Fahrradfahrer entgegen. Und dann weiche ich auch immer aus. Ich finde das auch ein ungeschriebenes Gesetz, dass der, der auf der falschen Seite fährt, der hat auszuweichen, klar. So, und dann mache ich schon immer diese, sorry, Geste. Weißt du, ich habe immer diesen Dackelblick drauf, dieses, ich weiß, was soll ich machen, was soll ich machen. Und ich finde es auch dann so dein, das ist okay, dann ist alles gut. So ich finde, dann hat niemand auf mich zuzukommen und sagen, ja, Falschfahrer, Geisterfahrer. Nee, in dem Dackelblick kann niemand reagieren. Hat man nicht dann zu tun, weil ich finde, wenn man dann, ich weiche immer schön aus und so, ist ja genug Platz. Ja, das einzige was man machen kann ist ja,, ist ja, ist okay. Ist okay. Habe ich doch auch schon mal gemacht, Mensch. Habe ich immer von uns gemacht. Dieses Lippenschürzend und wirklich von oben. Gönner, gönnerhaft. Ja. Aber ich will wirklich, ich bin so ein Standfahrer, ohne Scheiß, ich fahre so, ich fahre schnell, aber kontrolliert. Aber du bist mit Helm unterwegs, hoffe ich. Ich fff. Das ist jetzt keine Antwort auf meine Frage. Das war ein lautes Ausatmen. Können Sie bitte entweder mit Ja oder mit einem antworten? Fahren Sie mit dem Fahrradhelm Fahrrad. Was soll ich da jetzt schreiben? Was ist das für ein ... Schreiben Sie mal gar nichts. Ja oder nein? Natürlich. Gut, ja. Nicht. Manch. Nein, das ist letztlich, was ich auch weiss, ist doof, mache ich nicht. Fahre ich nicht mit Helm. Aber sollte ich tun. Es gibt ja auch diese Airbags, diese Halskrausen, die man sich ummacht, die dann diese Bälle um einen herum bilden, wenn man sich hinfällt. Aber ich habe zu viel Angst davor, dass die aus Versehen auslösen. Mitten im schönen Fahrradflirt irgendwie, du wirst wieder auf deine Blumen angesprochen.
Tatsächlich heute hat sich mein Stuntraining ausgezahlt einmal, weil es ist was, also ich bin noch ein bisschen angeschlagen, ehrlich gesagt, kurz vor dieser Aufnahme. Ich war in der Innenstadt, habe mir einen Mantel gekauft, einen schönen Wintermantel und dann haben die mir so eine riesengroße Tüte gegeben dafür. Und normalerweise sage ich immer, nein danke, stopfst du meinen Rucksack, ich wollte diesen neuen Mantel jetzt nicht in meinen Rucksack stopfen, habe also diese grosse Tüte angenommen und bin dann mit meinem Fahrrad nach Hause gefahren. Leider Gottes ist es dann mitten vor so einem Restaurant, wo man auch draußen sitzen kann und wo wirklich packed war draußen, genau vor diesem Restaurant fahre ich bestimmt mit 25 kmh lang, diese Tüte verheddert sich in meinen Speichen und von wirklich 25 auf 0 kmh bleibt mein Fahrrad einfach stehen, kippt um nach vorne, ich gehe über den Lenker vor diesen ganzen Leuten, die alle aufspringen, wo ich auch sagen muss, so, das sah offensichtlich gut gefährlich aus, cool gefährlich aus.
Ja, nice.
Ja, cool.
Ich hatte gefühlt, hatte ich den Sturz unter Kontrolle.
Für mich wirkt das alles irgendwie abgerollend, cool und so, mir ist auch nichts passiert,
außer dass mein kleiner Finger jetzt wahnsinnig wehtut, aber und alle sind aufgesprungen und so.
Problem ist nur, ich hatte mein Kopfhör auch im Ohr, wo laut Highschool Musical lief, weshalb ich nicht verstanden, also dann haben die so etwas mit Sachen zugerufen und so. Ich habe jetzt mal antizipiert, dass sie gerufen haben, alles okay, alles gut, und ich habe viel zu laut, weil ich auch das Verhältnis zu meiner Stimme durch die Kopfhörer und die laute Musik verloren habe, viel zu laut, obwohl die sehr nahe vor mir standen, gerufen, alles gut, alles super, und dann habe ich die Tüte, und dann ist so, jetzt ist die Frage, weil da habe ich auf die andere Strassenseite geguckt, da standen auch irgendwie tausend Gruppen, die stehen geblieben waren und so, heisst, an diesem Ort jetzt hier habe ich nichts mehr zu gewinnen, weil man geht ja auch ein bisschen durch die Welt, auch gerade wenn ich so, also man versucht schon cool zu sein immer, ich glaube, bei dir ist das ein bisschen anders, ich glaube, ich bin eitler als du und so. Man versucht irgendwie, also man will cool sein, man will cool auf Leute wirken und so. Ich weiß, dieses Areal hier gerade ist verbrannte Erde. Hier kann ich nicht mehr gewinnen. Also gebe ich mir auch keine Mühe mehr. Freiheit. Also schön einfach Rücksicht auf den Baubausstein gestellt, auf die Strasse gesetzt,, neben das Fahrrad gesetzt und dann einfach diese Tüte da rausgekramt. Aber es war mir auch nicht mehr unangenehm, weil ich weiß, es ist gerade etwas viel Peinlicheres passiert. Alles gut und so und dann hat man das Fahrrad irgendwie reparieren können einigermaßen, irgendwie kriegt alles. Man hat dann doch den Rucksack gestopft und so und dann wieder um die Ecke gebogen. Und sobald wieder niemand von den Leuten im Blick war, war ich wieder der Alte, war ich wieder, habe ich mich verhalten wie vorher. Aber für einen kurzen Moment hat man den echten Stefan Tietze gewählt. Für den kurzen Moment war ich da einfach komplett eins zu eins. Und dann blickt man um die Ecke, man weiß, hier ist niemand mehr, der es gerade beobachtet hat. Neuanfang. Ja, das ist wie wenn du auf eine Bühne gehst und du weißt, okay, jetzt darf ich nochmal. Das ist wie dieser unwissende Dritte, der dabei war. Von dem kannst du nicht, das ist wie das Mitwisser. der ist so wie dein First-Person-Spieler. Ja, der Erzähler. Ja, der Erzähler, der, wo am Ende rauskommt, der hat die ganze Geschichte erzählt, crazy, aber wir waren ja noch bei diesem einen Moment nur dabei. Und genau so ist es jetzt dabei, wobei man um die Ecke biegt, du kannst wieder Hochschal, du kannst wieder Hochschal, du kannst wieder alle Karten werden neu gemischt. Und du hörst in deinen Ohren nur, und hier ist Stefan Tietze, und du kommst wieder auf die neue Bühne und kannst wieder performen. Und dann siehst du plötzlich, ah nein, das war das Mädchen, was mich gerade gesehen hat. Scheiße. Siehst du drei, drei, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck. Scheiße, und dann plötzlich, Moment mal, warum kribbelt mein Hals? Oh nein, Ball, zack, Bälle im Gesicht. Wenn da dieser Airbag, der wäre nämlich losgegangen.
Ja.
Ohne Scheiß, ich denke mir, ich bin so froh, dass ich dieses Ding heute nicht gehabt hätte, weil ich bin so übertrieben über den Lenker gegangen, dass auf jeden Fall wäre dieses Ding aufgegangen.
Aber es wäre völlig übertrieben gewesen.
Und dann musst du das da wieder so reinknibbeln und es ploppt immer wieder so raus.
Ist das wie so eine Kapuze in manchen Jacken, die man so reinrollen kann, weiß ich nicht, wie das dann läuft. Ist ein tolles Startup, Mensch. Unterstützt dich doch mal. Das sind tolle Innovatoren da draußen. Können wir mal einladen, gerne. Jedenfalls hatte ich dann diesen Unfall und dann war ich um die Ecke und ich dachte mir, ja, war krass. Also der Hochstatus-T-Shirt wird immer wieder neu gemischt. Hol den Helm, Stefan. Vergess es nicht. Hol den Helm. Nächste Woche will ich dich hier mit dem Helm sehen. Ich will dich mit ganz platt gedrückten Locken sehen. Mit ganz platt gedrückten pinken Locken will ich dich hier sehen. Was sind denn die besten Helme? Diese runden Skaterhelme? Egal, Stefan, das ist doch egal. Hauptsache, du stirbst nicht, wenn du das nächste Mal... Du, ich kann dich hier nicht sterben sehen. Ich habe ein Helm geschenkt bekommen von Booselboards. Perfekt. Booselhelm. Perfekt, nimm denelm. Boosterboards ist pleite, habe ich schon erwähnt eigentlich?
Echt? Ja. Boosterboards
ist kein Thing mehr.
Ja, weil du auf Instagram
gepostet hast, dass du fast gestorben wärst auf so einem Ding.
Ne, soll ich mal kurz ein Behind-the-Scenes-Kram
erzählen?
Wir haben die ja,
ich habe die dann zusammen mit
Philipp, dem
Producer der Show, haben wir den reingeschrieben, die Boosted Boards.
In die Serie How to Sell Works on Netflix. Immer noch verfügbar. Immer noch auf Netflix zu gucken, aber nur noch eine Woche. Falls euch die Serie gefällt, schaut mal auf IMDB vorbei. So auch vorbei. Und dann dachten wir natürlich, ja cool, kriegen wir ein paar Boards geschickt, so für den Dreh und vielleicht kann man da auch eins behalten, mal gucken, dann kamen die uns ein paar Boards geschickt und so.
Und dann war es aber tatsächlich so, dass wir, ich glaube, dass unser anderer Chef, der wollte dann auch noch gerne ein Board haben und dann wurde dann nochmal angerufen und dann hat sich schon niemand mehr gemeldet.
Und dabei hatten die uns eigentlich sehr viele Boards mal versprochen für diesen Auftritt. Ist ja auch einigermassen normal, dass man dann mit solchen Firmen zusammenarbeitet und so, wenn man dann so ein Produkt in der Sendung hat. Deswegen hast du ja bei Netflix am Anfang immer auch unterstützt durch Produktplatzierungen stehen und so. Bei uns gibt es eigentlich kaum Produkte, die featured werden. Boosted Boots haben wir auch Spaß an ihm wieder genommen. Und dann haben wir uns schon so gewundert, weil dann wurde da ein paar mal angerufen und niemand wurde erreicht. Und dann dachten wir schon, die Ghosten uns, weil die kein Board mehr rausgeben wollen. Ja, ist ja okay, kein Problem, wir können ja mit dem leben, was wir jetzt noch haben. Ja, kam raus, Boosted Board ist pleite, es hell. Wirklich nicht gut gewirtschaftet, augenscheinlich. Einfach haben es nicht gepackt, sind weg. Scheiße. Boosted Board ist nicht mehr am Start. Und genau in dem Moment, wo Caesar erstochen wird hinter den Kulissen, genau in dem Moment, wo das Imperium zusammenbricht, da habt ihr diese Boosted Boards noch bekommen, als letzte Amtshandlung. Ja, vielleicht haben wir, weil die uns kostenlos ein Board geschickt haben, sind die Platte gegangen. Scheiße. Ja. Aber ist es nicht trotzdem in der Serie jetzt drin gewesen? Ja, ist drin gewesen. Kann man trotzdem reinschneiden. Ja, ich mache mir da keine Sorgen, aber krass. Ja, das tut mir jetzt aber auch irgendwie leid. Aber vielleicht brauchen nicht alle Menschen motorisierte Longboards. Das heißt, du als Person hast die gesamte Ära Boosted Board mitgemacht. Noch bevor das erste Boosted Board rauskam, hast du es schon bestellt, im Podcast erwähnt, hast du es schon Geld gezahlt, hattest es dann als einer der Ersten
und du hast vielleicht die letzten
Boosted Boards, die je produziert wurden,
hast du für die Serie
angeheuert. Du hast dieses
Unternehmen komplett mit. Begleitet
einfach mal. Begleitet von der Geburt
bis zum Tod. Wow.
Ja gut, wie wow, war jetzt auch nicht lang.
Naja, ich find's interessant,
das ist eine Geschichte. Nächste Woche muss einmal die Folge ausfallen, weil ich im Urlaub bin. Gut, also. Dan war jetzt auch nicht lang. Naja, ich find's interessant, das ist eine Geschichte.
Nächste Woche muss einmal die Folge ausfallen, weil ich im Urlaub bin.
Gut, also... Danach geht's direkt weiter.
In zwei Wochen kommt die nächste Folge, bis dahin wünschen wir euch ganz, ganz viel Spaß und wir heben ab.
Wir heben nämlich ab.
Ciao.
Macht's gut, ciao!
Stefan.
Das ist ein Wurstbillprodukt.